- Now performing "Loved" from his album,
"When a Crooner Dies," which is out today,
everybody give it up for Leslie Odom, Jr.
(audience applauds)
(audience cheers)
♪ Show 'em you've been loved ♪
♪ Show 'em how I loved you ♪
♪ You came to sing your song ♪
♪ They just came to record you ♪
♪ Oh, wring me dry, wring me dry ♪
♪ Pour out all the water from inside ♪
♪ Oh, let it shine through ♪
♪ Show 'em you've been loved ♪
♪ Show 'em how I loved you ♪
♪ Pray with me, my son,
then go rest your head ♪
♪ Sing our favorite songs,
the ones we sang back when ♪
♪ What's a memory for if we let 'em die ♪
♪ Live forever in a lovе
that's always alive ♪
♪ These ain't tеars ♪
♪ They're rain drops
from answered prayers ♪
♪ Life is an eye, blink,
we cry then we leave ♪
♪ The joy in your eyes
never lies, let 'em see ♪
♪ Show 'em you've been loved ♪
♪ Show 'em how I loved you ♪
♪ You came to sing your song ♪
♪ They just came to record you ♪
♪ Oh, wring me dry, wring me dry ♪
♪ Pour out all the water from inside ♪
♪ Oh, let it shine through ♪
♪ Show 'em you've been loved ♪
♪ Show 'em how I loved you ♪
♪ Make me real, I don't
want to be a hologram ♪
♪ Let me heal every shadow
till I'm born again ♪
♪ All I keep is this
hope, one day at a time ♪
♪ All I see is this
mountain's another climb ♪
♪ Till I learn to love me for who I am ♪
♪ Life is an eye, blink,
we cry then we leave ♪
♪ The joy in your eyes
never lies, let 'em see ♪
♪ Show 'em you've been loved ♪
♪ Show 'em how I loved you ♪
♪ You came to sing your song ♪
♪ They just came to record you ♪
♪ Oh, wring me dry, wring me dry ♪
♪ Pour out all the water from inside ♪
♪ Oh, let it shine through ♪
♪ Show 'em you've been loved ♪
♪ Show 'em how I loved you ♪
(soft music)
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
- Wow! So beautiful.
Oh my gosh.
Once more, let's hear it for
Leslie Odom, Jr. "Loved."
Pick up his new album,
"When a Crooner Dies."
It's out today.
We'll be right back with (indistinct).